Mädchen oder junge frau oder mann diese beiden auswahlmöglichkeiten reichen lange nicht denn schätzung zufolge gibt es mindestens
80.000 menschen in deutschland die nicht eindeutig sie oder er sind intersexuell nennt man diese personen dann jetzt hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden
im geburtenregister muss demnächst ein dritter geschlechts eintrag möglich sein was
intersexualität genau bedeutet und weitere spannende facts zum so genannten dritten geschlecht jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Im team rosa oder team blau mädchen oder junge nicht immer lässt sich bei der geburt tatsächlich eine
eindeutige antwort auf diese frage finden denn es gibt neugeborene bei denen das geschlecht eben nicht eindeutig erkennbar ist schätzung zufolge
Ist das bei 1 zu 2000 bis 1 zu 5000 neugeborenen der fall
ihnen wird dann nach der absprache zwischen ärzten und eltern einfach ein geschlecht
zugewiesen denn die kinder sind natürlich nicht selbst in der lage zu entscheiden dann folgen entsprechende
hormonbehandlung und
im kleinkindalter wurden früher fielen dann auch die genitalien operiert damit sie danach möglichst
eindeutig ein penis oder eine scheibe haben die betroffenen erfahren das ganze dann oft sehr viel später die eingriffe können zu
psychischen problemen führen
Und es ist natürlich eine absolute katastrophe wenn andere über das geschlecht entschieden haben und damit falsch liegen deshalb werden solche
Geschlechtsumwandlung heute frühestens mit 14 und besser erst ab 18 gemacht es gibt
zudem noch menschen bei denen nicht direkt bei der geburt auffällt dass sie zwischen den geschlechtern sind bei manchen mädchen
Entwickelt sich plötzlich in der pubertät eine tiefe stimme den jungs wachsen brüste viele von
Ihnen sind jahrelang auf der suche nach ihrer identität bei anderen fällt es erst
im erwachsenenalter auf beispielsweise werden dann bei einer vermeintlichen frau boden
Im bauch festgestellt hinzu kommt eine wohl
hohe dunkelziffer an menschen die zwischen den geschlechtern stehen bei denen das aber nie medizinisch
Diagnostiziert worden ist diese menschen die sich also weder als frauen noch als mann identifizieren also quasi zwischen den geschlechtern stehen nennt man
intersexuell das kann auf genetischer
Körperlicher oder hormoneller ebene der fall sein bisher sind 20 varianten der intersexualität bekannt manche von
Ihnen sind genetisch an mädchen haben aber ein penis weil ihr körper so viel testosteron
produziert andere sehen äußerlich aus wie ein mädchen haben aber ein männliches y-chromosom in ihrem erbgut doch wie
entwickelt sich überhaupt unsere geschlechtsidentität dabei spielen mehrere
Aspekte eine rolle natürlich gibt es zum einen körperlichen merkmale aber auch soziale einflüsse sind bringt die hormone der stoffwechsel aber auch die
Anatomie bestimmen letztendlich dann wie sich eine person geschlechtlich einordnet und als was sie sich sexuell
identifiziert hierbei spielen auch das psychische empfinden und die eigene biografie eine rolle das große problem der
intersexuellen in unserer gesellschaft ist unsere gesellschaft denn sie teilt ihnen genau zwei geschlechter auf und vergisst dabei
schätzungsweise mindestens
80.000 menschen in deutschland die sich eben nicht
eindeutig als sie oder er identifizieren in formularen beispielsweise gibt es genau zwei auswahlmöglichkeiten
Männlich oder weiblich frau oder mann bisher haben sie nur eine möglichkeit ihr geschlecht, im personenregister
austragen, zu lassen heißt also kein geschlecht keine gute option findet auch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in karlsruhe hat jetzt vor kurzem entschieden, im geburtenregister
Muss ist ein drittes geschlecht geben in einer pressemitteilung von anfang november heisst es das allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht
artikel 2 absatz 1 in verbindung mit artikel 1 absatz 1 grundgesetz
schützt auch die geschlechtliche identität derjenigen die sich dauerhaft
weder den männlichen noch dem weiblichen geschlecht zuordnen lassen darüber hinaus verstößt das geld in der personenstandsrecht auch gegen das diskriminierungsverbot
artikel 3 absatz 3 grundgesetz so weit die eintragung eines anderen geschlechts als männlich oder weiblich
ausgeschlossen wird bis ende 2018 habe der gesetzgeber jetzt zeit eine neuregelung, zu schaffen heißt also neben den auswahlmöglichkeiten
männlich oder weiblich eine weitere positive bezeichnung des geschlechts
aufzunehmen möglich wären beispielsweise begriffe wie divers oder inter in seinem beschluss geht das gericht übrigens von bis zu
160000 intersexuellen in deutschland aus die entscheidung wird von vielen gefeiert der deutsche ethikrat
beispielsweise hatte solch einen schritt schon 2012 gefordert als historische entscheidung zur gleichbehandlung hinter geschlechtlicher menschen
bezeichnet die antidiskriminierungsstelle des bundes dem beschluss
Aus karlsruhe wer übrigens mehr zum thema erfahren möchte sollte unbedingt zum thementag
Hinter geschlechtlichkeit der humboldt law klinik für grund- und menschenrechte am 27
November in berlin gehen den link dazu gibt es hier
Und natürlich in der video beschreibung hier geht es weiter einfach draufklicken dafür mit einstein und die leute die neueinsteiger
Geht es um frauen in der wissenschaft und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran